To build an analytics model,
let us discuss the variables
we used.
First, we used the
13,000 diagnoses.
It's for the codes for diagnosis
that claims data utilize.
There were also 22,000
different codes for procedures
and 45,000 codes for
prescription drugs.
To work with this massive
amount of variables,
we aggregated the
variables as follows.
Out of the 13,000 diagnoses, we
defined 217 diagnosis groups.
Out of the 20,000 procedures,
we aggregated the data
to develop 213 procedure groups.
And, finally, from 45,000
prescription drugs,
we developed 189
therapeutic groups.
To illustrate an example of how
we infer further information
from the data, the
graph here shows
on the horizontal axis, time,
and on the vertical axis,
costs in thousands of dollars.
So patient one is a patient
who, on a monthly basis,
has costs on the order of
$10,000 to $15,000, a fairly
significant cost but
fairly constant in time.
Patient two has
also an annual cost
of a similar size
to patient one.
But in all but the third
month, the costs are almost $0.
Whereas in the third month,
it cost about $70,000.
In fact, this is
additional data we
defined indicating
whether the patient has
a chronic or an acute condition.
In addition to the initial
variables, the 217 procedure
groups, and 189 drugs,
and so forth, we also
defined in collaboration
with medical doctors,
269 medically-defined rules.
For example, the
first type of rule
indicates the interaction
between various indices.
For example, obesity
and depression.
Then new variables
regarding interaction
between diagnosis and age.
For example, more than
65 years old and coronary
artery disease.
Noncompliance with treatment.
For example, non-fulfillment
of a particular drug order.
And, finally, illness severity.
For example, severe
depression as
opposed to regular depression.
And the last set of variables
involve demographic information
like gender and age.
An important aspect
of the variables
are the variables
related to cost.
So rather than using
costs directly,
we bucketed costs and considered
everyone in the group equally.
So we defined five buckets.
So the buckets were
partitioned in such a way
so that 20% of all
costs is in bucket five,
20% is in bucket
four, and so forth.
So the partitions were from 0
to 3,000, from 3,000 to 8,000,
from 8,000 to 19,000,
from 19,000 to 55,000,
and above 55,000.
The number of patients
that were below 3,000
was-- 78% of the patients
had costs below 3,000.
Just to remind you,
we created a bucket
so that the total cost in each
bucket was 20% of the total.
But the number of patients
in bucket one, for example,
is very high (78%).
Let us interpret the
buckets medically.
So this shows the
various levels of risk.
Bucket one consists of patients
that have rather low risk.
Bucket two has what is
called emerging risk.
In bucket three,
moderate level of risk.
Bucket four, high risk.
And bucket five, very high risk.
So from a medical perspective,
buckets two and three,
the medical and the
moderate risk patients,
are candidates for
wellness programs.
Whereas bucket four,
the high risk patients,
are candidates for disease
management programs.
And finally bucket five,
the very high risk patients,
are candidates for
case management.